All the experts,
by that I mean the NYP dea and the FBI
agree I should be dead
and somehow I managed to get through
this horrendous experience.
First of all,
I stayed very calm.
I stopped,
I thought I listened.
I didn't do anything without calculating
the,
the power and the impact of my words.
For example,
Stanley,
it's your birthday.
Wow.
You deserve something nice for your
birthday.
How about a sexual favor for your
birthday?
Obviously they didn't use those words,
but I won't say them on camera here.
Um,
and
going slow and being calm and thinking
about it,
I realized that if I said no,
I might be very offensive.
Why doesn't this lawyer?
I think that our girls are good enough
for him.
So I was very careful to answer in a way
to not offend.
So I said,
well,
I'm sure the girls are lovely,
but considering my circumstances,
I'd really rather not made it seem
light,
but yet very respectful.
And actually many hours later I had the
opposite problem because they were
smoking marijuana.
They were in a good mood and I'm
blindfolded with my own scarf covering
most of my face and one of the men said,
well,
these,
you know,
Stanley,
uh,
I think these girls are starting to like
you.
They're looking at your lips.
And that gave me the opposite problem
because if we went down that path and
their,
their girlfriends liked me,
they could get angry at me for the fact
that their girlfriends like me.
So I had to deflect it in the opposite
fashion.
And I and I,
and in that instance I used humor,
which I think you have to use very
carefully in these situations,
but humor is another thing in the
arsenal of,
of a hostage,
but only to be used sparingly and with
great care.
And I said,
really the only reason these girls like
me is because most of my faces covered.
And they thought that was hysterical and
they burst out laughing.
Now,
the fact is,
if you use humor the wrong way,
it can twist against you.
For example,
there was a point at which they,
again,
they are high on weed.
They've had sex with the girls,
this is the second time around.
I was there for 25 hours and and they
start,
one of them started imitating a Jamaican
accent.
Well,
I'm very good at doing all sorts of
different accents and I pondered very
carefully whether to go with it and go
where they were and I made a decision to
do it so I imitated my Jamaican accent
for them and they loved that.
It was,
it was hysterical to them.
The thought that this polished pressed a
Caucasian attorney could be imitating a
Jamaican accent was was hysterical to
them,
but then they were talking about a store
that was owned by Indians and I thought,
well,
should I do another kind of accent just
to have some fun and keep things light?
And I said,
no,
let me stop because I didn't know it and
others.
As long as I was doing an accident that
they were doing,
I thought,
okay,
that's far enough,
but don't take it any further.
You just don't know when they might
twist against you.
So I think survival skills stay very
calm.
Think,
listen,
observe,
understand your circumstances.
Also,
give up your ego,
give up who you are.
I was a federal prosecutor in that
position.
I had considerable power in this
position that I was in.
I had no power at all except the power
of my wits,
which I tried to get by with a but,
but,
but understand that you're no longer who
you are.
I'm in the situation and adjust to that.
So that's another principle I would say
for survival is to be very flexible.
You know,
getting the car guns pointed at me,
you know,
if I was inflexible,
I might've started,
you know,
yelling,
fighting,
uh,
all the detectives I spoke to say,
listen,
you can't second guess yourself Stanley,
because you managed to survive.
And I think because I was flexible I was
able to go with the situation that
helped me a lot.
And another thing you need to do is feel
some sense of empowerment.
I mean,
let's look at my thing,
how much control that I have.
I had seven people with automatic
weapons on me who could have killed me
at any moment and who might have killed
me at any moment.
And I have no doubt in my mind,
nor does the Myp dea or the FBI,
that they were perfectly capable of
doing it.
Yet there were certain things where I
felt I needed to keep control.
For example,
when I first went in,
they invited me to take off my shoes.
I said they put me down in a mattress.
They took off my trench coat.
I kept my sport jacket on,
but they invited me to take off my
shoes.
And you know what I thought in my head,
I thought a guy with his shoes off isn't
walking out.
Very powerful symbolism.
So I said,
no thanks.
I'll leave them on because in my mind,
and I think in the psychology of the
room,
a man with his shoes on could walk out,
a man with his shoes off might not get
the chance to walk out.
Or for example,
uh,
there was the point in time I purposely
didn't ask to go to the bathroom.
I didn't want to ask for anything that
wasn't offered to me.
But they eventually asked me if I needed
to use the bathroom.
I said yes.
And as soon as I said just,
they jumped up and sort of military
alert cocking the guns,
pointing them at me and it was,
they were nervous that on the way to the
bathroom I might pull something.
So again,
there I felt the need to maintain some
control even though they've got the guns
there,
they're in control still.
I wanted some small bit and I stopped
and I said,
Whoa,
whoa.
I didn't even get up.
I said,
Whoa,
hang on a second,
relax.
I'm not going to do anything.
All I'm going to do is go to the
bathroom.
And they calm down.
And then we went to the bathroom and I
didn't get shot.
Another example of maintaining some
control was when I first got in there,
they kept calling me,
stephen
and I kept saying,
my name is Steven Stanley.
They thought this was really funny.
Oh,
sorry.
Stanley Stevens,
the guy we did this to the other night
and it turns out later they had actually
taken him to the bank,
not that the apartment gotten his money
and then and then and then left him in
the backseat of his own car.
I felt that it was very important not to
be called Steven.
I felt that it was important to be
called by my correct name.
My name is Stanley because my identity
was my life.
If I'm a real person with a real name,
then you're less likely to kill me.
And so I maintained that bit of control.
So I think that's also to feel a sense
of some empowerment.
And if you.
If you read the studies of posttraumatic
stress disorder,
what they say is that people get
posttraumatic stress disorder because
they felt the complete disempowerment.
They felt the complete lack of control.
I was in a situation that was out of my
control for the most part,
but where I could find it,
I used it and also I gathered clues the
whole time.
So that to me,
although purely psychological was a form
of control for me to have.
Um,
so I think all those things helped me
survive.